we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's a
funny voicemail i received from the egg
man dave really enjoyed your interview
with john Hargrove the author of the
beneath the surface however I wish would
have asked them the really hard question
that everyone is thinking what about his
emotional and physical relationship with
these orcas and is it true that he's the
father of two cars baby I think there
might be some truth there yeah uh very
positive response Louis to the interview
with that former SeaWorld training uh
trainer the eggman is the only person
who was wondering whether the man
fathered killer whales at least the only
person who contacted us about that but
so many positive comments I found the
entire thing absolutely fascinating
particularly after watching the
documentary blackfish and seeing him in
it and just getting a chance to hear
from him directly very interesting moral
of the story don't give SeaWorld a dime
yeah and fortunately uh they are slowly
starting to wind down their program
although as John Hargrove told us
yesterday not quickly enough and a lot
of it is just PR nonsense on the bonus
show today Las Vegas might finally be
getting a pro sports team why has it
taken this long and what will be the
repercussions we will talk about it also
some conservatives are angry with Paul
Ryan and we're having a really hard time
figuring out why other than the fact
that very little that they do is ever
logical but but taking that apart as the
sort of baseline uh we are gonna look at
the specifics of this and also the Dalai
Lama has said that prayer is all well
and good but really action is what makes
change happen in the world and it is a
very enlightened view from one of the
well of most well-known religious and
spiritual leaders on our planet we will
talk about all of those stories and more
on the bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership is how you get instant access
to the bonus show and of course if you
ever do any shopping on amazon.com if
before shopping you go to david
pakman.com slash amazon it'll send you
to amazon but then almost by sheer magic
anything you buy will support the work
we'd we do a little bit of your purchase
will come back to us and we really
appreciate everybody who does that on a
weekly basis